[Music]
josh
starts off this hour in idaho falls
idaho
hey josh how are you i'm doing well dave
how are you
better than i deserve what's up um so we
uh are working on baby step two uh we
started off with about two hundred and
three thousand
and we paid off about ninety thousand
since last august wow
um so we've been hitting it really hard
but part of that was we sold the house
in california and
idaho so that helped but um so
we have my son is four years old and
he's about to have a major surgery next
year
it'll be surgery number 10 for him wow
and so as we look forward to
uh yeah he's got some skeletal issues so
he's totally fine it's just they need to
fix some bone stuff
um and so as we look forward to that and
we begin planning for
for that process i'm looking at our debt
situation and i can pay off
by the time of his surgery about 46 000
by next year with some increased income
that's about to happen
uh and that's before we get the surgery
so my question really is is do i focus
on paying down that debt and saving four
hundred dollars a month in payments
um by the time we go to that surgery or
do i pause baby step two and save up
that the pile of money like i would for
a pregnancy of some sort like you
recommend
um and still have that afterwards
i just still have that debt there but if
we do that then i'll
by the time the surgery comes if i pause
but if i don't pause baby step two i'll
only have two deaths left to r2 vegas
so the momentum side of me wants to just
pay on baby step two and roll those new
medical bills into baby step two once
they come in i got you um just to keep
that momentum going so that's the
question how many how many kids have you
got
just him once we had him we wanted to
focus on uh
getting him taken care of yeah yeah
it sounds like the little guy's been
through it he has but he's
you never know he's the happiest kid in
the world yeah
kids that face that stuff are tough i
mean um
yes yeah but i'm not
my gosh it makes me cry ah poor little
guy
all right uh so uh the surgery that he's
having
your health insurance covers it uh
so we're not sure so part of that
scenario is my wife is going to start
her private practice
she's a clinical therapist and so we're
going to see a massive increase in
income
but that's also going to come with a
change of insurance
so we're not sure what that looks like
yet
um and as far as how much of a cover
plus his specialist
we're in idaho and the specialist who he
works with is in florida so it's going
to throw some wrenches into that so
we're just not sure what that looks like
yet
it will cover some of it it'll be
question of how much
okay all right well job one is take care
of him
sure and you'll get you'll get around to
the debt
uh and so to the extent you
actually have to pay money for the
surgery or for the medical
you're gonna you know once you define
what you need to do is spend a lot of
time and effort
uh clearly defining what your financial
exposure is what you
are going to have to pay okay
and then that gives us our number and i
need that number if i'm you
once i've got that number then that
number is
happens before any further debt
reduction happens
but if you but if you've got you know an
hsa with a 5 000
deductible and they pick up 100 cents on
the dollar after that then you need 5
000
shut up i mean you can figure that out
but if you need 56
000 it's a whole nother world right sure
so little guy little guy's number one
priority
okay we're gonna take care of our dadgum
family before we take care of a bunch of
debt goobs okay so that's it i mean you
know
no question about where your priorities
lie my priorities lie on that so i think
before you decide
whether you're going to have to stop
temporarily push pause like a pregnancy
or like a
potential job loss in the future meaning
you're not going to be working your baby
steps you're going to push pause and
pile up cash because
freaking hurricanes coming and we need a
storm shelter
and we could we it's very predictable we
know right where that thing is you know
so
but the trick is this we don't we don't
stop on
vague worries of uh and
surgery's not a vague worry but if you
just say oh he's got to have a surgery
well okay
but what is the cost to you that's what
makes the decision
it's not it's not that the surgery is
going to happen we're gonna we're gonna
do what we need to do for the little guy
so right yeah let's let's get the
insurance moved and in that process
figure out what
what you're liable for out of pocket
what you're gonna have to come up with
and then i would push pause
and matter of fact i go ahead and push
pause now but give yourself then 30 days
or 45 days to figure out
while you're piling up some cash what
your out of pocket is going to be with
these insurance changes and do you have
to travel to florida are you going to
pay the specialist to fly up to idaho i
don't know what do you
what's got to come out of your pocket
that insurance is not going to cover
and we need that money before we push
play again
okay that makes sense yeah it does it
was just one of those things of like we
have so much momentum and i can see that
well
and on the other hand what can you got
on the one side you got all this
momentum
but obviously you can't not take care of
the kid you know that
sure yeah and so yeah and people tend to
swing the other way and they go oh we're
having this surgery
so all bets are off and and then you
figure out that they're 5 000
out of pocket and basically from a
financial perspective
not an emotional perspective but from a
financial perspective they were being
drama queen
and they should have just kept plowing
because if you got 5 000 out of pocket
you budget that between now
and next year and you uh and you keep
plowing right
right yeah because with the increase
income we're anticipating having about 5
000 a month to be able to throw onto
debt it's going to be
pretty substantial and so you know you
just you're just going to in your budget
be ready for five yeah five or ten
thousand you can handle that
but if it's 50 or 60 000 you're looking
for out of pocket then we're gonna have
to stop and get ready take care of
little guy
right this is how you do it that's the
critical thinking process that you're
going to use to get at this
so that's very cool good i'm glad you're
there to take care of him i'm glad
he's got a dad and mom like he has
that's pretty cool little geyser
man they're tough uh we've certainly
with team members uh we've got about a
thousand folks working here and with
uh all the financial coaching over all
these years we've seen some
situations with the babies where you
just your heart is in your throat your
stomach's in your throat and you still
have to make good
solid decisions that you don't lose your
mind
uh and um you know go completely
off the rocker and you know just check
out what happens is people they just
okay i'm gonna i can't emotionally deal
with the money peace
and all of this stress with my baby
being sick
and so i'm just gonna work on the baby
being sick and i'm gonna let all the
money stuff go into
the toilet and see then that makes a
bigger mess
so what you have to do is you have to
get reserve a little bit in your tank to
make sure you're dealing with the money
stuff
so that you're there emotionally and
financially
for the needs of the child it's tough
man that's tough that's heartbreaking